this is lucy james reading for ben janka
a new adventure awaits the warriors of
light in end walker the latest expansion
for square enix's popular mmo final
fantasy 14. not only is end walker
wrapping up a huge intricate story that
spans over 10 years but it's also
bringing us two new jobs as well as the
male vieira and a ton of new content on
top oh and there's also a whole moon to
explore end walker launches on december
7th officially or on the third if you
pre-ordered for early access on both
playstation 4 and 5 as well as pc steam
and mac to prepare you for it we thought
we would gather up everything you need
to know about the new expansion before
it arrives
the big thing here is that final fantasy
xiv director naoki yoshida and his
dedicated team have put in the extra
work to ensure that the conclusion of
the heidelin and zodiac saga is
fittingly epic the story started all the
way back with the long wiped out 1.0
version of the game and has lasted for a
decade and this narrative is the game's
strongest selling point for those eager
for story content we know so far that
end walker is the biggest expansion yet
in terms of story and cut scenes in fact
it apparently has so much story content
it gives most single-player rpgs a run
for their money as far as what the story
is going to contain we only have a few
details as the dev team likes to keep
details close to their chest until the
game releases we know we are finally
going to locations fans have been very
excited to see old charlie vavnir and
garlimold and of course the moon as
exciting as the trip to the moon is we
still don't know exactly why or how we
get there but that doesn't mean we are
any less excited for it
while almost everything in final fantasy
xiv is built off of or around the story
there is still a lot more content to do
alongside the normal story progression
dungeons or raids a big one is the new
island sanctuaries mode which works sort
of like an animal crossing or harvest
moon game from what we can tell
apparently it also lets players build
out a home or other buildings on their
own private island outside of an initial
somewhat vague announcement most info
for this mode has been from various
interviews so in many ways square enix
is keeping details for that close to its
chest too although island sanctuaries is
coming in a later patch we won't have to
wait long but what we do have now is a
very nice bit of promotional art that
features the major general so it's
already one of the best things you'll
see another big set of changes are
coming to pvp courtesy of a free season
pass setup for progression as long as
you play pvp you'll be earning rewards
like mounts and gear which is a great
way to reduce fear of missing out for
players who may want some of the pvp
rewards but would prefer to just grind
it out instead of sweat it out in combat
to be in the top 100 players for a whole
server square enix mentioned possibly
bringing back old season rewards as well
so i'm holding out hope i can still get
my hands on that sweet season 19 armor i
missed additionally a new small scale
map for pvp that looks similar to a
payload map in overwatch is also on the
way it's 5 on 5 with no class
restrictions so it's sure to be an
interesting competitive time
with every expansion there is always
excitement about what new jobs will be
added for everyone to play this time
around we are getting a new physical
melee dps in the form of the reaper and
a shield based healer in the form of the
sage if you want to read or hear more
about them specifically or check out
some of the changes coming to other jobs
we do have a preview up on gamespot that
you can check out the impressions of
both were very favorable with sage
getting me excited to try healing even
as a tank main and reaper shaping up to
be my new favorite dps job both new jobs
do a great job of showing how much the
game has progressed stylistically and
mechanically with its jobs a lot of
skills are also being shuffled around
and every existing job gets to look
forward to new skills from level 80 to
90. some jobs like the summoner and monk
are getting bigger overhauls which all
seemed great during the preview event
the summoner's changes give it great
identity now that it actually summons
huge bosses and it feels even better to
play being the tank player that i am i
also really enjoyed the changes to
warrior and even paladin less fell
cleaves will always leave me sad but
that new overhead smash ability along
with the new punching one are already
making up for it who isn't excited about
paladins just getting tons of huge
swords to throw around now too
basically almost every job has something
exciting to look forward to and that's
always one of the coolest parts of a new
expansion
i know there are people out there that i
need to mention this specifically for as
people love their bunny boys people kept
asking and now they will receive and
walker finally brings male vieira into
final fantasy for the first time and i
am pretty sure it's going to change
eorzea as we know it say goodbye to all
your tall ellis and men and pointy-eared
catboys everyone who afks in limsa la
minsa is about to fantasia into a bunny
boy and there is no going back i love my
big dumber garden too much to change
myself but i am stoked to see everyone
else live their best lives that's all i
really have to say about mel vieira
we're all happy they're
here with the release of the next
expansion one of the big things that
everyone was hoping for was data center
travel or the ability to visit and play
with your friends no matter what server
they're on with end walker we are
finally getting just that the health of
an mmo is tied to its community and
having server and data center barriers
broken down means that the community
will be able to connect and thrive in
completely new and fun ways beyond
having a larger pool of pals to run
dungeons or raids with it also opens up
the avenue for visiting and seeing a lot
of really cool player driven content now
you'll be able to visit fully
functioning in-game nightclubs and
listen to live djs play music to full
concerts put on by bards or even plays
regardless of if they're happening on
your server or not personally there is
this player run aquarium that i have
always wanted to visit but it was on
another data center and now i can
finally go this is only going to be made
even better with the new housing
district players came together to build
in ishgard this means there will be tons
of new housing opportunities and new
places to visit once everyone gets
situated getting housing in final
fantasy 14 is no easy task but at least
this time there will be a lottery system
for players to get a better chance of
landing one however it shakes out i am
very excited to see what new places
people make to visit whether that's a
cute little coffee shop to hang out with
other people in or a massive concert
hall to serve as a venue for musical
performances with all this new stuff to
see a new level cap of 90 to get to and
new jobs to experience end walker is
shaping up to be a major content drop
for final fantasy 14. even if we don't
have specifics for a lot of what is
being introduced yet we have a good
grasp of what it all is
the scrapped 1.0 version of the game
around reborn heavensward stormblood and
shadowbringers have all led up to this
expansion and square enix wants it to
hit hard so it's no surprise that the
mystery is being maintained and walker
is going to be in our hands as early as
the 3rd of december when early access
launches so get your friends together
and dust off those swords and staves and
we'll see you there
[Music]
[Music]
you